ezra miller is seeking help after years
of bizarre behavior and headline making
legal troubles the flash star was
charged with felony burglary ezra miller
was arrested for disorderly conduct and
harassment i'm being arrested for
disorderly economy the actor's rep
shared a statement with variety quote
having recently gone through a time of
intense crisis i now understand that i
am suffering complex mental health
issues and have begun ongoing treatment
this is the first time ezra has publicly
commented on recent allegations they've
been arrested multiple times this year
in hawaii including for threatening to
bury a couple they also face allegations
of grooming multiple young girls as
young as 12. you learn it did you want
to fight is nothing new
on top of that ezra was captured on
video in iceland yelling at a woman
outside a bar then appearing to choke
her no charges were filed now ezra is
apologizing for their actions
quote i want to apologize to everyone
that i have alarmed and upset with my
past behavior i am committed to doing
the necessary work to get back to a
healthy safe and productive stage in my
life my favorite thing about this job
and this art form is being able to
change you know what i mean and try
different things and so i hope i can
keep
moving further and further out that's
that's the hope this all comes amid a
lot of industry questions about ezra's
future in hollywood what are your
superpowers again
i'm rich ezra plays the flash in the d.c
cinematic universe
and the trades report warner brothers
the studio behind dc is scrambling to
figure out the future of a 200 million
dollar standalone movie focused on
ezra's character amid the actors
troubles the movie's been in the works
since 2016. it's really so much fun it's
such a
an unbelievable license to play
the character creates so many
opportunities
for
exploration of
all sorts of things
physics the mind
humor neurosis trauma the flash for me
that story it's it's love versus death
the flash is still set for release next
june and features ben affleck as batman
e.t has reached out to warner brothers
for comment
[Music]
you